[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voici l'année nouvelle
la france on a vécu beaucoup
cependant elle voit venir celle ci sans
manquer à l'espérance car elle set où
elle en est ce qu'elle vaut et ce
qu'elle veut en algérie
la france en tant que d'une manière ou
d'une autre
se termine les conditions actuelles
de l'engagement politique économique
financier administratif et militaire qui
la tient liées à ce pays
et qui s'il restait ce qu'il est
ne saurait être pour elle
une entreprise à homme et à fonds perdus
alors que tant d'autres tâches
appelle ses efforts ailleurs
cependant
dès lors qu aurait cessé les combats et
les attentats
elle serait disposé à
apporter sa coopération un état algérien
souverain et indépendant
procédant du libre suffrages des
habitants
pour lui
que ses intérêts essentiels soient
garanties en échange de ce qu'elle
fournirait
actuellement
encore
c'est là la solution qui lui paraît la
meilleure
part que l'association des communautés
algérienne il trouverait sans doute
sa chance
est parce qu il pourrait en sortir des
rapports d'avenir c'est qu'on
entre elle-même d'une pas
l'algérie et l'afrique du nord d'autre
part
le président des états unis du mexique
monsieur adolphe lopez matéos ouvert à
mexico le congrès international de la
presse filmée manifestation
professionnelle mais qui a ouvert aux
congressistes une fenêtre sur cette
capitale qui dès 1950 dépassait et les
deux millions d'habitants où les femmes
aux larges pantalons traditionnelles
côtoient la statue de pasteur où la
pauvreté voisinent avec les banques
ultramoderne m'ont poussé à côté d
église du vieux style espagnol des
buildings futuristes comme la faculté
des sciences
le pittoresque
c'est le marché de toluca cité de plus
de 100000 habitants qu'il a offert avec
son indien qui tricotent pour tuer le
temps et ses poteries héritage des
lointains aztèque ce sont encore les
combats de coqs que les sociétés
protectrices des animaux ont banni
d'europe et dont le goût demeure
toujours aussi vivace dans tout le
mexique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sans oublier la plage à la mode acapulco
[Musique]
combien tu crois encore la grève de
decazeville depuis plus de 10 jours 15
cents mineurs font la grève dans leurs
puits chaque jour leur famille leur
envoie les provisions qui leur
permettront un jour de plus de vivres
sur les lieux de leur travail et les
jours passent
une fois par jour les mineurs du fonds
volontairement immobilisé à 300 mètres
sous terre remonte à la lumière le temps
de fumer quelques cigarettes
puisqu'on ne fume pas en dha d'embrasser
les enfants de prendre une douche et
puis ils redescendent reprendre une
faction santerne santerne parce que le
problème touche à la fois la raison et
le sentiment c'est le drame de la
reconversion les mines de decazeville ne
sont plus rentables mais les mineurs
habitués à leur mine de père en fils se
refuse à être recasés ils veulent que
continue cette exploitation déficitaire
et toutes cases ville dans ces heures de
crise vie la vie de ceux qui restent en
bas rues vides commerçants militants et
dans chaque foyer à la table de midi des
chaises vides
[Musique]
et
à
la municipalité elle même a voulu
prendre parti derrière son air elle a
donné sa démission il semble que onze
autres communes avoisinantes les suivis
dans son geste
au milieu de cette population
sensibiliser les gestes naissent des
manifestations s'ébauche les femmes de
mineurs un millier peut être se sont
rendus à rodez pour réclamer au préfet
la reprise de l'exploitation et le
problème dépasse de beaucoup le bout
sentimentale d'un métier traditionnel il
faut que le pays puisse vivre d'autre
chose si la mine n'est plus capable de
le faire vivre et c'est là le vrai
problème
[Musique]
le bruit facteur de choix
multiples effet
le bruit qui est la vie
notre compagnon lorsqu'il parle soit tu
y as de carreau
est un poison violent un moment donné
redoutable fléau dans les villes
modernes et même à la campagne
le bruit des mesures et qui ne finit
jamais détruit notre organisme halpern
option ruine notre existence
en bourdonnant diamant invétéré il noie
honte partout à chaque instant du il est
même de la touche
les sons que nous aimons lorsqu'ils
viennent à propos deviennent
insupportables quand il faut les
entendre alors qu'on en veut pas
la plupart des personnes qui sont à
l'usiné
au bureau
[Musique]
à la maison irrité intoxiqué malhab
souhaite que vivement des lois efficaces
des méthodes nouvelles viennent les
délivrer de ce maudit bac à
la ligue française contre le bruit
reçoit du monde entier d à peine
saisissant des victimes d'horloge huit
coups tous les quarts d'heure les petits
des heures en plus les plaintes des
enfants implorant le silence le soir à
la maison et c'est encore les cloches
une église de consomm 13140 coup toutes
les 24 heures
la preuve a été faite que les plaignant
du bruit ne sont pas des maniaques le
bruit les a touchés souvent profondément
en débordant l'oreille après l'avoir les
et il peut troubler la vue le système
nerveux et la respiration les naturelles
sans accélérer les battements du coeur
atteindre les tissus musculaires
nous n'oublierons jamais le préfet de
police qui libéra paris de l'enfer des
klaxons et il est bien dommage de devoir
constater que des gens insolent
renouvelle parfois leurs cristaux
tintamarre
le plaisir de certains dans leurs
pantoufles ormes ce cycle est pétarader
bien fort bien d'autres condamnés par un
récent décret invitant ces personnes à
faire vérifier le bruit de leurs
machines
[Musique]
dans certaines usines les sons les plus
cruels qui dépassent parfois le seuil de
la douleur ont été muselés avec vos
coudes adresse il faudrait bien qu
ailleurs l'intention soit la même
d'écarter le danger partout où ils se
trouvent
l'urbanisme moderne à penser soleil air
espace verdure il faut casser splendeur
s'ajoute le silence déjà en s'élevant
les demeures enfuis les bruits de
l'extérieur un écran tissons est fournie
par les arbres et si les architectes et
les entrepreneurs chaque fois qu'ils
construisent un immeuble et tu dit avec
soin le moyen le meilleur de l'ain
sonorisé us de matériaux à leur
disposition de laine de verre saint
gobain qui s'adapte à toutes les
solutions ou d'éléments pour eux comme
le caoutchouc bulgomme enfin de plots en
feuilles mince s'appliquant sur cloisons
et planchers
ou bien de tissus molletonné le logis
tourmenté retrouvera le calme le monde
du travail le répit mérité
mais ce répit on le trouvera surtout si
chacun pensant à la paix des autres au
respect que l'on doit à ce qui nous
entoure
quand le re habitude de ne pas faire de
bruit
les cloches et plus fameuses de londres
celle de sainte mère ilbo n'avait pas
retenti depuis le blitz de 1941 en
présence du lord-maire le duc
d'edimbourg est venu ranimer le célèbre
carillon refondu et restaurer et avec
une autorité qui n'excluait pas la
délicatesse
les cloches de mairie le bo ont donc pu
annoncer leurs nouveaux comme elle le
fit naguère chaque année
[Musique]
à grenade ce sont des meilleurs crieur
d'espagne qui ont fait entendre leur
voix à l'occasion de la fin de l'année
et les femmes n'étaient pas les derniers
[Musique]
improvisé ou non ce sont certainement
les voeux les plus énergiques ont été
exprimées pour 1962
rappelle pas mais
[Musique]
et c'est un homme qui une fois n'est pas
coutume eu le dernier mot andrez lapèze
salaires hinault
[Musique]
comme chaque année enfin en angleterre
l'auberge des checkers a réuni les plus
énergiques sonneurs de trompes de chasse
aussi bien que de trombes d'eau il faut
du temps pour se livrer à ce sport un
certain souffle et l' on en déduira
qu'ils en ont en angleterre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
les traditions comme on voir est salie
une année chasse l'autre n'est selon des
rites établi
[Musique]
au havre le commandant croisille a fait
au président rené coty les honneurs du
france 97 ans après la mise en service
du paquebot du même nom avec l'ancien
président de la république 400 invités
participaient à la première traverser la
manche avant l'atlantique
une répétition générale en quelque sorte
pour le commandant croisille et ses
hommes est l'occasion de saluer au
passage le liberté pour les 400 invités
ce devait être l'occasion de découvrir
les aménagements de la cité flottante
longue de 315 mètres prévus pour
recevoir 2400 passagers le fumoir des
premières classes par exemple qui occupe
toute la largeur du navire soit 32 mais
les cuisines dont il suffit de préciser
qu'elles sont à la mesure de ce futur
palace de l'atlantique
sous ce dôme étoilé qui la domine de 5
mètres cinquante de haut la salle à
manger
[Musique]
la salle de spectacle la plus grande qui
ait jamais été construite sur un navire
et qui possède une capacité de 664 place
[Musique]
tel est le luxe 400 âmes town où il ne
faisait que le courte escale le france a
offert aux personnalités du corps
britanniques et notamment à son
ordinaire féminin une prochaine
croisière aux canaries permettra
d'apprécier un peu plus ses qualités et
ce sera enfin ouverte la route de new
york bonne chance donc aux france
la semaine ont déjà passé depuis que la
capitale du territoire de goa pas jim
est tombé au pouvoir des troupes
indiennes le président des roues ayant
acheté trente mille hommes sur la très
ancienne possession portugaise que
défend des 3000 hommes les portugais ont
été écrasés et gola est tombé au bout de
36 heures surmonter aujourd'hui des
couleurs indiennes
l'ex résidence du gouverneur portugais
est devenu le quartier général du chef
de l'armée d'occupation
[Musique]
on sait que goa vivait à l'ombre du
drapeau portugais depuis 450 6 l'apôtre
traditionnel de la non violence n'a pas
hésité devant un coup de force pour
occuper gua à l'encontre de toute loi
internationale on peut se demander que
peuvent vouloir dire les déclarations
coutumière de missionnaires ou touchant
l'emploi de la force
à ce ponton le pakistan dont karachi la
capitale offre le spectacle pittoresque
d'une ville que se partagent des images
contrastées d'un passé millénaire et
d'un présent très actuel s'émeut devant
certaines menaces venues de
concentration de troupes indiennes aux
abords de la frontière du cachemire le
souvenir semble bien passer des jours de
1953 où monsieur ayrault venait rendre
visite au chef du gouvernement
pakistanais monsieur mohamed a lieu le
temps des embrassades qui succédait à la
décision de l'onu réclamant un
plébiscite des populations du cachemire
plébiscite qui n'ont d'ailleurs jamais
lieu s'est rapidement évanouie
le pakistan pays musulman craint de
revoir les jo de 1947 où les forces
indiennes reprirent par la force
possession de territoires dont la
population musulmane voulait rejoindre
l'état pakistanais
l'intervention de l'onu en 1949
les saints les adversaires en présence
le long d'une ligne d'armistice
frontières dont le provisoire dure
encore depuis le cachemire est resté
entre les deux états une pomme de
discorde
monsieur nehru va-t-il vouloir à nouveau
trancher par les armes une vieille
querelle
[Musique]
vieux fer femmes les autres que roger
louis dupuy a exposé dans une galerie
parisienne ne sont rien d'autre en effet
que de vieux outils ou de vieilles
ferrailles qu'il a glané un peu partout
mais il a ajouté à leur présentation ce
petit rien qui s'appelle les talents et
ses vieux faire maintenant vie
un groupe de hachoir voici huit jeunes
faisaient
bloc de charrue des conspirateurs
belles grappes un pic ce vaisseau du
guesclin
de fer à cheval et un conduit porsche
ferdinand le taureau
[Musique]
une tôle à sable une pelle à foin a
derrière
[Musique]
et mme arthaud de géologues le que tout
cela
deux cisaille de fil à plomb les clowns
[Musique]
mieux faire d'amore en effet et si peu
qu'on paie les substituer à des scènes
quotidiennes
soyez sages des mamans
[Musique]
l'auto stop
un droit de conduire
la partie de pétanque et
[Musique]
paris c'est un peu la capitale du
football breton il y avait près de 20000
bretons en effet sur les 35000
spectateurs du parc des princes pour
assister au match de coupe de france
rennes racing club de paris c'est sans
doute pour cela que les rennais maillot
français ont marqué le 1er but durant la
première mi temps ils ont donné
l'impression qu'ils pouvaient battre les
parisiens grâce à un football pas
compliqué mais efficace dans sa
conception
les choses ont changé en deuxième mi
temps
sur cette action cénacle numéro 10 tirs
au but et jacky bien placé dévie la
balle les parisiens gagnent
deux autres bus parisiens vont suivre
bien que les rennais net à aucun moment
baissé les bras bien au contraire
deuxième but dans un angle impossible
signé bollini et le troisième c'est
encore lui qui va le signer après une
descente de multi novik
3 1 le racing est qualifié pour les
seizièmes de finale
il ne s'agit pas là d'une autoroute
américaine ce réseau routier
ultramoderne est situé aux portes
d'abidjan abidjan carrefour du sport
africain à l'occasion des jeux de
l'amitié auquel ont participé également
les athlètes français la france se
devait d'apporter son concours à ses
amis d'afrique noire ainsi durant une
semaine abidjan s'est transformée en
capitale olympique
[Musique]
ces magnifiques installations sportives
sont sortis de terre en moins de trois
mois ce qui constitue un exploit assez
rare le président houphouët boigny et
monsieur maurice herzog ont présidé
cette première grande confrontation du
sport africain et français
[Musique]
et maintenant défilé des délégations
pour marquer l'an 1 des jeux de l'amitié
qui deviendront peut-être un jour les
jeux olympiques de l'afrique noire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le palais des sports parisien est archi
comble pour le combat de poids moyens
vannuchi annexes
annexes toujours puissants se met
rapidement en action
panucci le corps son adversaire culotte
noire à bandes blanches qui a beaucoup
de supporteurs dans la salle lui impose
un combat violent rapide
il ne s'agit pas là de deux stylistes
mais deux boxeurs de tempérament qui se
rendent coupables
[Applaudissements]
ce travail de démolition réciproque ne
donne finalement aucun résultat les deux
boxeurs reste debout le combat va
jusqu'à la limite
il n'est en définitive ni vainqueur ni
vaincu mais pour un ex l'issue de ce
combat aura été dramatique le verdict à
peine rendue on lui apprenait la mort
subite de son père
[Applaudissements]
dans les arènes du pardo les aficionados
madrilènes ont participé bien malgré eux
au plus gros gag tauromachique de
l'année et pourtant il était venu avec
l'espoir d'assister à la consécration
d'un futur grand matador on le leur
avait dit du mois
ce futur grand matador candau baisse a
rapidement transformé la novillada en
charlotade c'est ce que nous lui
pardonneront jamais les amoureux de la
corrida
il est vrai que sans vouloir cordoba
s'est moqué d'eux en revanche pour ceux
qui ne sont pas puristes le numéro de
corde en baisse ne manque pas de saveur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est peut-être là le début d'une
nouvelle vague de matador
dans l'arctique cordobès veut à tout
prix triomphé du tout et n'importe les
moyens
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans cette aventure cordobès a au moins
gagné une chose il a mis les rieurs de
son côté
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à bruxelles après un mois de débats
difficiles qui ont voué deux experts à
la crise cardiaque les ministres de
l'agriculture des six sont parvenus à un
accord cet accord ouvrira dès juillet un
marché de 160 millions de clients aux
agriculteurs des six pays ils mettent en
action la deuxième étape du marché
commun prévu par le traité de rome
[Musique]
neige froid et tempêtes les deux tiers
des états unis ont suivi l'assaut de la
masse d'air glacé venus du canada le
plus rigoureux enregistré depuis le
début du siècle - 22 à denver dans le
colorado où l'élégance s'adapte au froid
à
les enfants eux ont mis au point un
nouveau jeu
[Musique]
il reste que les palmiers d'atlanta en
géorgie ont permis tout à coup déplacer
dans le paysage un peu partout le trafic
est devenu quasiment impossible et la
circulation a été coupée sauf exception
qui confirme la règle
un hiver rigoureux dans les régions les
plus ensoleillées ont cette fois porté
la marque
[Musique]
en angleterre le trident a remis un peu
de chaleur dans les coeurs britannique
cousin de la caravelle à la mode de
grande bretagne il en a adopté des
réacteurs à l'arrière du fuselage le
nouvel appareil a fait ses premiers pas
si l'on peut dire devant sergio frais de
la viande et quelques 6000 spectateurs
capable de transporter une centaine de
passagers à 960 km heure on compte
beaucoup sur lui au pays de shakespeare
pour effacer les échecs successifs des
malheureux connect
où
en inde la conjoncture astrale de ce
début d'année à jeter dans la
consternation les brahmanes et les
fakirs qui ont appelé les fidèles à la
prière depuis pour conjurer le mauvais
sort il prit réunis à la nouvelle des
vies devant une noix de coco fruits qui
permet de se concilier les faveurs
divines et jettent sans désemparer du
beurre fondu dans les flammes la
combinaison des planètes et elle en
effet que de graves événements peuvent
être imminent pareil combinaison
n'avait-elle pas amener voici huit cents
ans une invasion du pays et quelque
temps plus tôt il y a cinq mille ans
n'avait-elle pas déjà provoqué une
guerre désastreuse alors les fakirs prix
pour conjurer le sort et sans doute
sont-ils fondés à croire en l'efficacité
de leurs actions pour peu qu il la
compare à celle de la diplomatie
internationale
je
[Musique]
ya dix ans disparaissait le maréchal de
lattre de tassigny
de lattre de tassigny vous vous souvenez
on n'a pas oublié les scènes qui
jalonnèrent scène le 16 août 1944 le
pavillon du général de lattre flotte est
en vue des côtes de provence les troupes
placées sous ses ordres devenue la
première armée française en tanet la
marche victorieuse qui allait les
conduire sans désemparer jusqu'en alsace
[Musique]
et dans colmar delattre recevait le
baiser d'une province libéré
le 31 mars 45 avec un matériel de
fortune laure a été franchi et quelques
mois après l'ennemi mettait bas les
armes et capitulait
[Musique]
c'était alors l'arrivée à l'improviste
de dollars auprès de montgomery
eisenhower et joukov imposant la
présence française à l'armistice de
berne
[Musique]
d'autres images montrent du passé un
jour aux invalides on avait vu un père
salué la dépouille de son fils qu'il
avait décoré lui même en indochine
enfin l'heure où soulac de l'étoile le
président de la république déposa sur
son cercueil le bâton de maréchal ou la
france rendait hommage au grand soldat
qu'il avait bien servi de notre dame aux
invalides à travers paris le général
eisenhower le maréchal montgomery
avaient accompagné leurs compagnons de
lutte avec les généraux français les
membres du gouvernement et des corps
constitués
il y a de cela 10 en disant qu'ils
peuvent suffire peut-être pour oublier
mais qui n'empêche pas de se souvenir
[Applaudissements]
face à la célèbre colline de fourvière
de l'autre côté de la saône c'est le
vieux lion trop vieux même puisque dans
la rue mercière qui fut la plus passante
de lyon au moyen-âge des magasins fermés
annonce des démolitions prochaine tout
un quartier usé par le temps va en effet
disparaître et qui songerait à regretter
ces maisons l'épreuve et pourtant et
pourtant le quai saint-antoine c'est
aussi au milieu des rideaux de fer
aujourd'hui tirer une enseigne une
enseigne qui porte le nom d'une aventure
ici nati guignols vers la fin du xviiie
siècle depuis lors sans doute il avait
conquis la france mais il était resté
fidèle à son théâtre chargé de dorures
du quai saint-antoine
[Musique]
certes les marionnettes que laurent
mourguet sculpta en 1800 mia francs le
savent qui est bachique madelon les
pouces truculente et le plus célèbre de
tous d'une yole ne sont plus aujourd'hui
que des pièces de musée
certes la salle ne connais plus
aujourd'hui que des assistances
enfantine mais guignols continue sa vie
de théâtre entre les mains vigilante de
son actuel animateur ernest neige sauser
80 ans il s'est acquis de nouveaux
partenaires
ernest neige aux airs lui même mais
aussi d'autres et non des moindres
edouard herriot charles de gaulle
en plus d'un siècle et demi le
répertoire n'a cessé de son côté de
s'enrichir les valeurs vallée du début
voisines et vers les années 25 au milieu
de trois cents pièces diverses avec
faust et l'on compte aujourd'hui un
guignol parachutistes superproduction
bien sûr américano lyonnais tu quand le
quai saint-antoine disparaîtra il faudra
quand même regretter le théâtre de
morgen il naquit guignols
ces trois points marqués par l'écossé
smith à la 15e minute du match du
tournoi des six nations opposant les
cosses maillot blanc à la france sur le
terrain demeurent et fils ont donné le
frisson à tous les supporteurs français
à ce moment les écossais dominé leurs
adversaires de la tête et des épaules
égalisation inespérée de la france sur
coup-franc également 15 minutes plus
tard
deuxième mi temps malgré quelques rares
attaques françaises les avants écossais
domine toujours le match
et pourtant c'est la france qui prend
l'avantagé encore sur coup franc tiré
une nouvelle fois par albaladejo le demi
d'ouverture ce second coup de pied
inespéré fait basculer le match en
faveur des français
toutes les attaques écossaise échoué par
manque d'imagination alors que celle de
l'équipe de france improvisé pour la
plupart sème la panique chez leurs
adversaires
et c'est une de ces attaques qui se
termine par le magnifique essai de
rancoule que transforme albaladejo 11 à
3 l'équipe de france a bien commencé
dans ce tournoi 62e qu'elle peut gagner
comme celui de l'an dernier
[Musique]
cinq villages et 5000 personnes
peut-être sont engloutis sous cet énorme
fleuve de névez et de roches qui a
descendu en trombe les pentes du mont
bhaskaran le plus haut sommet du pérou
sous l'action d'un brusque réchauffement
de la température
l'effroyable avalanche s'écrasa dans le
plus grand fleuve côtier du pays
déclenchant sur le cours inférieur un
raz-de-marée qui balaya la vallée sans
cadavre seulement ont été retrouvés les
autres zizou sous linceul gris épais de
plusieurs mètres qui couvre une largeur
de 2 km
[Musique]
la ville de drague ford en angleterre
doit faire face à une dramatique
situation si 8000 pakistanais y sont
établis depuis longtemps ce groupe de
population s'accroît au moment de noël
de visiteurs venus directement de leur
pays or si les précautions sanitaires à
l'arrivée à karachi sont draconiennes
elle semble l'être beaucoup moins au
départ c'est ce qui fait qu'un voyageur
atteint par la terrible maladie qui fait
chaque année plus de cent mille victimes
aux indes a pu débarquer et contaminé
l'angleterre depuis les candidats à la
vaccination forment des queues
interminables aux portes des hôpitaux
les cliniques et les pharmacies sont
assiégées et on a ouvert à londres un
dispensaire spéciale
ses troupes en armes dans les rues de
djakarta montirat plan heureusement ne
sont que des manoeuvres que le président
souk arnaud en conflit avec la hollande
au sujet de la nouvelle guinée faits se
déroulaient à l'intérieur de la capitale
dans ce climat le maréchal égyptien
abdel rabb climat maire est venu lui
apporter l'appui du colonel nasser
décidés à ne pas laisser passer par le
canal de suez les forces ou des renforts
néerlandais ce qui ne va pas manquer de
compliquer la route du porte-avions
hollandais karel doorman qui vient de
quitter rotterdam pour une croisière de
trois mois dans le pacifique
[Musique]
amari 17 plasticage en une seule journée
c'est on l'espère un record qui ne sera
pas battu l'attentât commis au ministère
des affaires étrangères et l'une des
plus dramatiques illustration de ce
terrorisme qui enrichit maintenant tous
les français deux morts plusieurs
blessés graves des dégâts importants
les mesures sévères ont été prises
contre cette vague d'attentats
chaque nuit maintenant la police procède
au contrôle des voitures en circulation
contrôle sévère et qui en concordance
avec le renforcement des surveillances
et l'aggravation des répressions devra
réduire les possibilités des plastiques
heures
éteindre at on bientôt lincendie de
gassi touil au fond du sahara des
bulldozer déblaie les ferrailles et les
débris de toutes sortes éjecté du puits
par l'explosion
[Musique]
les pompes géantes ont pompé à 800
mètres de profondeur des milliers de
mètres cubes d'eau stockées aujourd'hui
dans deux réservoirs en matière
plastique de 5000 mètres cubes chacun
puis à l'aide de bulldozer à cabine
blindés munis de crochets géant on
ramènera les ferrailles l'incandescente
qui encombrent les abords du puits
restera alors à souffler à l'aide de
l'explosif le plus puissant la flamme de
300 mètres qui consomment des fortunes
et illumine le désert
[Musique]
pour percer les secrets de l'univers
l'homme a besoin d'instruments toujours
plus puissants toujours plus précis et
le radiotélescope de joindre albenque en
angleterre vient d'être dépassée par les
installations de l'observatoire de paris
annonçait annonçait on s'était borné
jusqu'ici à l'étude des éruptions
solaires les batteries de
radiotélescopes en écoutait les
palpitations
[Musique]
désormais on veut aller aux limites de
l'univers et pour ça on a renoncé au
système de jeu de rennes banques qui
n'ont de précision annonce est un miroir
plan mobile un miroir concave fixe un
récepteur les radios source reçu par le
miroir mobiles sont réfléchis sur le
miroir fixe qui l'est concentre et les
renvoie sur le récepteur
[Musique]
le miroir mobile un rideau de maille
métallique long de 40 mètres et qui
achevait en mesurera 90 des moteurs
lorient à volonté
[Musique]
lui faisant face le miroir fixe un autre
réseau de maille métallique de 35 mètres
de haut et de 65 de large en attendant
d'en mesurer 300 solidement ancrées dans
le sol et rendu parfaitement rigide par
une armature de soutènement sa surface
concorde a pour rôle de concentrer les
ondes en un faisceau de cap m de
diamètre dirigé sur l'antenne de
réception
est le résultat de tout ceci ce sont ces
enregistrements d'apparence anodine
d'apparence seulement car ils révéleront
par exemple une collision de galaxies
l'agonie de milliards de systèmes
solaires et de leur planète
la formation d'une nébuleuse ou telle
anomalie de la nébuleuse d'andromède que
la lumière n'est sans milan a traversée
de bout en bout
avec cet appareil
l'homme atteindra des distances de 7 ou
8 milliards d'années-lumière qu'aucun
télescopes ne peut atteindre sur ces
graphiques il lira l'histoire
fantastique des mondes qui naissent ou
qui meurent aux limites de l'univers
si l'univers a des limites
[Musique]
canaveral c'était la répétition générale
première américains promis au voyage
autour de la terre le colonel glen à
repasser son rôle et quels rôles dans
tous les détails il a d'abord essayé son
habitacle dans la capsule mercury cet
habitacle dont il disait quand on y est
enfermé on a l'impression de n'être
qu'une pièce supplémentaire la plus
importante naturellement
il était avec les techniciens de la nasa
à l'arrivée de l'avion cargo qui amenait
monstre enfanter un monstre la fusée
atlas
un jour sans doute de tels préparatifs
d'un vol n'auront plus rien pour nous
étonner et seront devenus spectacle
banal mais reconnaissons qu'il ya
aujourd'hui dans ce déploiement de
machinerie de quoi nous laisser rêveur
la capsule mercury était maintenant
lizin place au sommet de la fusée atlas
il ne restait plus qu'une scène à jouer
du premier acte la scène du débat
[Musique]
le camion ou glenn s'étaient préparés
arrivé sur l'air de lancement un terrien
en descendait comme diraient les
martiales
[Musique]
john glenn comme alan shepard et virgil
grissom prenait l'ascenseur pour gagner
l'habitacle dans lequel il était entendu
qu'il ferait bientôt une fois deux fois
ou trois fois le tour de la tête
et la dernière cène s'achever par la
répétition du décompte fatidique des
minutes
ainsi s'envoler les terriens john glenn
était prêt
[Musique]
et route des français et de tous les
favoris en général dans la descente du
hahnenkamm à kitzbühel en autriche le
vainqueur le suisse philippe forest
personne ne l'attendait
pourtant depuis quelques années foreurs
est l'un des meilleurs descendeurs du
monde et sa victoire dans la descente du
hahnenkamm n'est sans doute pas dû au
hasard mais à sa grande maîtrise
c'est avec aisance et sang froid qu'il
triomphe de toutes les difficultés à
plus de 100 à l'heure comme guy périllat
l'an dernier
[Musique]
une fiche de consolation pour les
français la très bonne performance de la
classe biberon du ski féminin
marielle goitschel qui est encore à
l'âge où l'on joue à la poupée se joue
des difficultés du slalom féminin de
badgad stein avec la dextérité d'une
grande championne
[Musique]
elle est déjà une grande championne en
moins d'une saison elle est devenu le
chef de file du ski féminin français
sa seconde place à bagdad stein devant
les meilleure skieuse du monde leproux
simplement
ip rien après son très mauvais
classement dans la descente de kitzbühel
avec une revanche à prendre dans le sla
[Musique]
apprenant des risques qui en donnait le
frisson aux spectateurs il a bien failli
retrouver une première place à laquelle
ils s'étaient habitués depuis l'an
dernier
seulement là encore personne n'avait
pensé aux outsider et périllat s'était
coiffée sur le poteau par ferries un
américain presque inconnu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
e
pour son premier grand voyage avant le
départ pour new york le paquebot france
a pris contact avec l'atlantique les
canaris ces îles de l'éternel était
était le but de la croisière qui a
permis à 1600 privilégiée de découvrir
la joie de vivre à bord de la nouvelle
ville flat en longeur timide à la
piscine mais des amateurs décidé pour le
gymnase
une fréquentation honnête des
nourritures de l'esprit à la
bibliothèque 2000 value
le bar ne manqua pas non plus de clients
disons de visiteurs qui évidemment la
décoration seul ne pouvait manquer
d'attirer
la salle à manger quant à elle autour de
madame de gaulle la marraine du france
faisaient si l'on peut dire l'unanimité
ainsi se rebelle et le personnel et les
différents services chargés de donner
son rythme à la vie du navire
le soir venu la musique entraînait les
couples comme il s'y est aux soirées des
vacances de luxe
un bateau qui fait la vie belle elle
aura été en somme la conclusion des 1600
qui furent de la croisière au canada
la caravelle a depuis longtemps conquis
les airs et la célébrité on connaît
moins son père spirituel l'ingénieur
pierre siv qui fut le créateur génial de
ce magnifique appareil air france en
baptisant du nom de sa ville natale
grenoble la 28e caravelle de son armada
qui est en même temps la 100ème sortie
de lusine a tenu à lui rendre un hommage
mérité
on pouvait craindre à l'occasion de
l'anniversaire du 24 janvier qu alger ne
céda à une nouvelle vague de violence il
n'en a heureusement bien été si de
nombreuses fenêtres ont pavoisé la
présence très apparente de puissantes
forces de police dans les rues privées
de transports publics et dans les
grandes artères interdites à la
circulation des véhicules manifestait la
volonté du gouvernement de ne pas voir
s'installer à nouveau le désordre le
calme donc n'a pas été troublé le centre
de la ville conserva toute la journée
son caractère paisible par petits
groupes les algérois 20 déposé des
fleurs au pied des arbres près desquels
tombèrent voici deux ans les victimes de
la fusillade
à 17h magasins et bureaux fermaient
leurs portes une foule nombreuse se
rassemblent à près du plateau des
glières et aux alentours de la rue
charles péguy au dessus desquels
passaient et repassaient l'hélicoptère
de la police et cette foule soudain se
figea pour une pathétique minute de
silence alger pendant sept minutes en
honorant ses morts at elle pu jusqu au
fond repenser le grand problème qui
l'agitent et qui hélas a troublé et
trouble encore temps de conscience
[Musique]
sucre de canne sucre de betterave la vie
moderne us indifféremment des deux mais
se souvient ton de cet autre temps où le
sucre de canne en jolie pin aiguë orné
seuls les rayons des épiceries
il fut un temps en effet voici plus d'un
siècle et demi ou les plantations de
canne à sucre des antilles et de
louisiane étaient seuls pourvoyeuses
d'une industrie où s'approvisionner le
monde entier or les guerres de la
révolution puis de lempire ni en péril
dans ce domaine l'approvisionnement de
la france la flotte anglaise avait coupé
la route du sucre et napoléon fit
rechercher un produit de remplacement un
ersatz comme on dit aujourd'hui ce fut
benjamin delessert un fils de banquier
qui utilisant les travaux intérieurs par
vata experts le sucre de betterave est
présente à l'empereur voici juste 150
ans les deux premiers pains née de son
industrie l'empereur lui décerna
immédiatement la première licence de
fabrication qui comportait une exemption
d'impôt est à visiter la première
fabrique industrielles établies au
village de passy en un lieu qu'on peut
encore déterminer mais qui a depuis bien
changé d'aspect n'y en 1814 200 fabrique
du même genre fonctionner en france et
produisait annuellement trois mille
tonnes de sucre trente ans après leur
nombre atteignait 500 le succès de
benjamin delessert c'était donc affirmer
sans toutefois convaincre tout le monde
car si napoléon satisfait pas le décor
est lui-même de la légion d'honneur les
détracteurs ne manquaient pas et la
presse du temps transmis nombre d'échos
de la guerre des deux sucres ou la
betterave en général n'avait pas le beau
rôle
en dépit de cette bagarre la betterave
gagne à la partie et les quelques 400
mille hectares consacrés en france
chaque année à la betterave en sont la
preuve la plus formelle les moyens
mécaniques d'aujourd'hui
l'amélioration des transports ont amené
depuis quelques 25 ans une concentration
industrielle dont les installations sont
capables de produire pour certaines de
30 à 40 mille tonnes de sucre par an
n'est devancé machine qui presque sans
le secours de l'homme sont passés d'un
mouvement continu de la betterave
brutaux morceaux de sucre calibré
pensant un instinct à la première
sucrerie de passif et de nos un coup de
chapeau à benjamin delessert
[Musique]
grande foule à vincennes pour le prix
d'amérique
40 millions de prix et un duel attendu
new star à fond de mme hasina qui lui
rend 25 mais ça n'est pas encore le
moment de la passion madame et monsieur
rêve
quant à cette autre monsieur ils
hésitent
[Musique]
attention ils vont partir ils sont
partis
tha
vous allez voir new star numéro 13
prendre la peine voici new star qui se
détache
elle accentue maintenant mettra pas
naître son avance les autres concurrents
sont lâchés
m
finalement mme hasina n'ayant pas pu
remonter son handicap new star ne sera
pas rejoint et c'est dans une très belle
foule est qu elle franchi le poteau
d'arrivée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
21e rallye automobile de monter card
4000 kilomètres contre 350 équipage
partie des quatre coins d'europe vont
passer trois nuits et quatre jours sur
les routes
[Musique]
cette année le temps s'est révélée
beaucoup plus clément que les années
précédentes et 120 équipages réussiront
à parvenir au but final monte carlo
néanmoins les concurrents rencontré sur
leur chemin neige et verglas qui
provoquèrent quelques dérapages
[Musique]
après avoir abordé une des dernières
difficultés du parcours on plonge
surnoté carlo où l'équipage suédois carl
sonnac bonne sur sable numéro 303 arrive
en tête
il reste encore des preuves de vitesse à
discuter mais au décompte final des
points ce sont les suédois qui
triompheront dans ce 31e rallye
[Musique]
suivant la tradition les trophées leur
sont remis par les souverain monégasque
m
à
[Musique]
les succès d'elvis presley de paul anka
de vince taylor et de johnny hallyday
ont fait école toute la jeunesse de rap
est saisi par l'europe et même en
pologne où des amateurs s'efforce
allègrement de suivre les traces de ses
funambulesque héros de notre époque
[Musique]
vdb
harper
[Musique]
et
qu'on ne s'y trompe pas ce n'est pas un
public de 12 illuminés qui se pressent à
cette présentation ce serait plutôt des
connaisseurs les approfondisse heures
des philosophes du rhum
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allons allons il y a de l'espoir
que
[Musique]